some Taylor Swift fans may have a
Ticketmaster hangover this morning after
trying for hours and I mean hours to buy
tickets to her upcoming tour yesterday
and many came up empty-handed a pre-sale
for Swift's era's tour in the US was hit
by overwhelming demand you can imagine
of course it's Taylor Swift and that
left thousands of fans experiencing long
wait some as long as eight hours oh wow
many reported technical glitches and
website crashes some swifties this is my
favorite part the internet is going to
internet they took the social media
event one post of this photo remember
this picture yeah and they wrote Our
Taylor Swift pre-sale War Room Zoom yeah
showing The Situation Room at the White
House of course another said the world's
population has officially reached 8
billion people and they are all in the
Taylor Swift they're all in the Taylor
Swift pre-sale queue uh other people did
not find it very funny Congressman Dave
system mean tweeted Ticket Masters
excessive wait times and fees are
completely unacceptable it is no secret
that Live Nation Ticketmaster is an
unchecked Monopoly called on the justice
department to investigate what during
the chaos Ticketmaster tweets that there
had been historically unprecedented
Demand with Millions showing up to buy
tickets for Swift's tour and thank
people for their patience